Well, good morning church.
Welcome to this gathering of Henderson Hills.
My name's John, one of the pastors here.
If you're new to our church, we would love to meet you.
There's a new here area out in the lobby.
Just go say hello and uh, let us know you're here.
We'd love to let you know a little bit about us.
Uh, if you call Henderson Hills home too, it is great
to see you.
We love you being here as well.
So today, uh, is something
that we call typically good, uh, Palm Sunday.
Wow. I got ahead of myself a little bit there.
Palm Sunday, which looks back
to Jesus' final entrance into Jerusalem
before he was eventually crucified a few days later on
what we call Good Friday.
Uh, and so that means, of course what that uh, looks forward
to is Easter Sunday next week, resurrection day,
where we will see that, uh, we gather together
and we need to add a service for the space issues
that we typically run into on Easter.
And so there are different times next Sunday.
Just remember that 8, 9 30, 11,
if you can consider attending the eight
or the 11 that would help us
with serving our guests that day.
Uh, just so you know. But that's coming up this next week.
And so thankful for this week to remind us, refocus us.
I'm excited about it As we get into Palm Sunday today
though, uh, let's start with some audience participation.
Raise your hand if your life is perfect.
Okay, good. Nobody. Alright, that's good to know.
Um, no, nobody did. Right. My hand's not up.
Your hand isn't up. Of course.
And we know that's kinda a silly question. Yet.
Here's what I know many are struggling with.
You think at least you're tempted to think
everyone's life is perfect except yours.
And so you feel like there's something wrong with you.
And listen, Instagram doesn't help us with this, right?
You have this, this filtered version of life
that you put on there when the reality is something very
much different than what is often seen there.
But, but that's the projection is that life is perfect
for everybody else except for me.
But it's just not true, right?
So let's try it a little bit differently.
Raise your hand if there is something about your life
that you would like to be different.
Yes. Every one. Every one of us, right?
Like that's the truth. And we all have something in our
lives that we would like to change.
Some are struggling financially
and you're just trying to make ends meet.
Or you've got a health issue nobody can figure out.
Or your kids are rebelling
and you don't know how to handle that with your grandkids
and all those issues there.
Or maybe you're, they're getting bullied at school
or you have a dead end job
or something in the world is crisis
and you just feel like that's heavy on your soul right now.
Everyone has something we'd like different.
Now here's the thing we do with that is that we all then try
to seek solutions to those problems.
We all look for answers, solutions that will never satisfy.
And we do it because we want that button
that fixes everything.
We want deliverance, right?
We want that easy fix it button to make it all go away.
Listen, we're not the first ones to feel that.
We're not the first ones to look around at our world
and hope something would be different.
Look for deliverance, want and cry out for salvation.
We're not the first, but what's the real answer
if what we've tried over
and over again is not getting us there?
What's the real answer? Well, let me show you.
Take your copy of God's Word and turn with me to the gospel.
According to
Matthew, it's in the New Testament.
It's about two thirds of the way through.
You'll find the New Testament. Matthew is the first book.
The gospel according to Matthew, be in chapter 21,
big number 21 there.
And this is where Jesus entered Jerusalem couple days
before he ended up being crucified.
This is what we call the triumphal entry
or the palm Sunday, Matthew 21.
I'm gonna look at verses one through 17.
I'll read all of it, then we'll come back and look at it.
Now, when they drew near to Jerusalem, came to Beth Page
to the Mount of Olives, then Jesus sent two disciples, sang
to them, go into the village in front
of you immediately you'll find a donkey tide
and a cult with her.
Untie them and bring them to me.
If anyone says anything to you,
you shall say the Lord needs them
and he will send them at once.
This took place to fulfill what the prophet spoken
by the prophet saying, say to the daughter of Zion.
Behold, your king is coming to you humble
and mounted on a donkey, on a cult,
the full of a beast of burden.
So the disciples went and did as Jesus had directed them,
and they brought the donkey
and the cult put them, put on them their
cloaks, and he sat on them.
And most of the crowds spread their cloaks on the road.
And others cut branches from the trees
and spread them on the road.
And the crowds that went before him
and that followed him were shouting
Hosanna to the son of David.
Blessed is he who comes in the name of the Lord,
Hosanna in the highest.
And when he entered Jerusalem,
this whole city was stirred up saying, who is this?
And the crowd said, this is the prophet Jesus
from Nazarus of Galilee.
And Jesus entered the temple and drove out all who sold
and bought in the temple.
And he overturned the tables of the money changers
and the seats of those who sold pigeons.
And he said to them, it is written,
my house shall be called a house of prayer.
But you make it a dent of robbers And a blind.
And the lame came to him in the temple and he healed them.
But when the chief priest
and the scribes saw the wonderful things that he did, did,
and the children crying out in the temple, hosanna
to the son of David, they were indignant.
And they said to him, do you hear what these are saying?
And Jesus said to them, yes.
Have you never read outta the mouth
of infants and nursing babies?
You have prepared praise and leaving them.
He went out to the city, to Bethany and lodged there.
Lord, this is your word.
And clearly I need to get outta the way of this.
And so I trust you are gonna work and speak in spite of me.
I pray that you'll give, uh, clarity.
You'll speak through your word and your way
and your time to our hearts, that we'd be open in good soil
to receive it and that you would bear good fruit.
30, 60, a hundred fold for your glory for others, good
for our good through obedience
to your text that you've given us.
Thank you Lord in Jesus' name. Amen.
Now before we get too far into this,
there's a couple phrases
or words we saw in this that we need to define.
Help us understand what's even going on here.
And they were repeated a number of times in the passage.
And so first you saw the word hosanna.
People were shouting this, the kids were shouting this
hosanna, what does that word even mean?
Well, it's a combination of two Hebrew words
that they mash together.
And it basically just means save.
We pray, save us. We pray.
It was actually pretty common back in Jewish history.
It's used a number of times in the Psalms, especially
around the feast of the Tabernacles
that they would celebrate every year back in Israel.
And, and this was around that.
And there was this remembrance, there was,
shout the word hosanna.
Let me give an example. Psalm one 18 verse 25,
save us, we pray.
Oh Lord, oh Lord, give us success. We pray. Right?
They're, they're crying out both in a
looking back kind of way.
God thank you for saving us your uh, uh, exodus,
deliverance, all of that you thank you for saving us.
And it's also kinda looking forward that God,
we know we're gonna need a salvation again.
So save us, we pray it's back and forward.
So that's the way they were using it here
in Matthew 21, right?
Like there's this, this rejoicing over God's deliverance
and that he will, again,
there's a rejoicing here in Matthew 21.
They're praying for assistance from God
and they're attributing that
to God's anointed one, his Messiah.
In fact, here they see Jesus as that seeing him
as the savior that they were longing for.
And we know that's true, that that's what they were seeing
because of the way they say it.
Hosanna not just hosanna by itself, Hosanna to the son
of David, right?
So there's a added piece that they add on Hosanna
to the son of David.
Well what does that mean? Again,
that was a common term used for back then for the Messiah.
They took the Old Testament and the prophecies
and they mashed it all together.
And it came out with Messiah son of David,
that that was their term.
They knew from the promises given to David.
We'll look at it in a second. That Israel's greatest king,
they knew that God had promised David that from his lineage
the Messiah would come.
How do we know that's true? Well second Samuel,
we'll study second Samuel this fall.
It says this. This is what God says to David,
the greatest king Israel ever had.
He said, wait, there's something better coming.
Verse 12, when your days David are fulfilled
and you lie down with your fathers, meaning you die,
I God will raise up your offspring
after you who shall come from your body, your family.
And I will establish his kingdom.
He shall build a house for my name.
I will establish the throne of his kingdom.
For I will be to him a father.
He shall be to me a son when he commits iniquity.
I will discipline with the rod of men,
with the stripes of the sons of men.
But my steadfast love will not depart from him
as I took it from Saul, whom I put away from
before you and your house.
And your kingdom shall be made sure forever before me.
Your throne shall be established forever.
And so those people in Jerusalem who were shouting
Jesus's glory hosanna to the son of David, they knew
that none of David's lineage had actually
fulfilled that promise.
Yet that Romans were in town like they were not
reigning forever as is like there was something going on
that wasn't fulfilled yet of this promise through David.
And so they were longing for that.
They were looking, waiting for
anticipating this forever king to deliver them.
And so these crowds, as they heard about Jesus,
as they watched him with his compassion, his miracles,
they sure felt like this one's the one
the way Jesus spoke to their leaders.
It was like this guy, he's coming
into blow the whole thing up.
This is the one on.
Except there was a massive problem.
They were actually looking for the wrong kind of savior.
They weren't wrong in looking for the Savior.
They were looking for the wrong kind of savior.
Most of those people, their primary focus was ridding
Israel's land of the hated Romans.
Those people who were corrupting God's promises
to his people, they were interpret,
they were invading the land.
He's like, get rid of 'em. That's our focus.
Yet what they missed was that God had a much bigger plan
than merely their comfort
and their prosperity in those borders of their nation.
God had something way bigger in mind.
They were looking past what God said eternal blessings were
and the the deep need they had for spiritual salvation,
they were looking past all that
to see they needed a political savior.
That's why many
of these same people ended up just a few days later calling
for his crucifixion.
Hosanna, save us. You're the one
Crucify.
Because they didn't get what they were wanting from him.
Now I did this this week, I, I was looking at that
and I'm sitting here thinking like how guys,
how could you have missed it?
Jesus was doing all these things.
He was saying all these things.
How could you have missed it?
It seems so obvious to us
yet let's give 'em a little grace here.
Okay? Like these people, their desire for
what they were desiring, that same desire is in every one
of us too, isn't it?
Like we're looking for a deliver, we're looking
for a savior, aren't we?
But are you looking for the wrong kind of savior?
Am I looking for a savior
who can merely make my life easier
or make my life more comfortable or take away my enemies
and make it all satisfying?
Am I looking for that kind of savior
or am I looking for the true savior?
See, here's, here's the big idea today.
If you're gonna write one thing down, if you do that,
if you don't, okay, lemme just
encourage you to remember this one thing.
If you only remember this, great. But here it is.
When you take all of this together,
Jesus came not to improve our kingdom,
but to bring us into his kingdom.
Right? There's a difference,
which is what they were looking for.
Like that you take their, their mindset
and how they're shouting and and saying and responding.
Jesus came not to improve our kingdom,
but to bring us into his
where he delivers us in
that kingdom from our deepest problems like sin
and death and ourselves.
He's not here to serve us and cater to us.
He is here to bring us into his
kingdom that he's the king of.
And many in that crowd missed it.
'cause what they were looking for was a new David
like they thought son of David, okay, well we're looking
for a new David who's gonna come in
and fulfill what David failed at,
what other people failed at as the king.
David is going to be the one
who could make Israel great again.
Let's do that. Let's look for that. Let's long for that.
They missed it. We often miss it too.
What we need to be looking for is far greater than
what they were looking for then A kingdom
of this world far greater than David,
far greater than anything we could search
for here we're looking towards the true and better.
David, the one that David himself was looking forward to.
I mean, you keep reading in Matthew 22, in 21 into 22.
Jesus himself affirms that statement
that David was looking to his Lord.
He was looking forward to a messiah
that David knew he wasn't the one.
And David wouldn't be if any of his sons be the one.
He was like, there's a messiah coming
who's gonna reign over everything.
So we can't look for a David ish figure
that's gonna save us here.
Any kingdom mindset here that's gonna save us,
deliver us, make our lives better.
What we gotta look for is the true and better.
David, the son of David who's proven himself here.
Yeah, here's what we learned about David
through the first Samuel series.
We learned that David is in many ways a type
of the Messiah.
He's somebody who exemplifies a lot of the characteristics
and we can learn from to show us who the Messiah is.
He wouldn't perfect at it.
But there's a reason the Messiah is referred to as Son
of David, right?
That David is a great example.
And so like I did last week, contrasting Saul
and Jesus to point us to the true king in many ways.
We can do the same thing with David
since he's the son of David.
Let's contrast, compare David and Jesus.
David had a lot more going for him.
We didn't compare Saul with anything.
We're gonna compare some of David with Jesus
to learn something about Jesus today because of it.
Contrast later. But we'll get to that.
But there's something similar first.
And Matthew 21 actually showed us that they both first,
they both fulfilled prophecy.
Both David and Jesus actually fulfilled prophecy.
Let's start with David. This is months ago.
But do you remember Hannah at the beginning, chapter two
of Samuel, she prayed to God
that he would give his king strength.
They didn't have a king yet.
They didn't even know they were gonna want a king.
And she said, give strength to your king exalt the horn
of your anointed.
That was eventually fulfilled, not in Saul, but in David.
Then think about when Samuel went to uh Saul
after Saul's first rebellion.
Saul looks at Samuel sa.
Samuel looks at Saul and says,
Yahweh has sought out a man after his own heart.
A phrase used about David over and over.
And then later when Samuel actually goes
to anoint the next king, he goes to this little village.
He has this family. There's eight sons land up
and he goes through the first seven.
None of those guys, the most unlikely one, happens
to be the one that God looks
and says The Lord sees not
as man sees man looks on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks on the heart, David.
And so David is the fulfillment of of prophecy
given to show that he's the one.
But David comparatively was nowhere close to the amount
of prophecies that Jesus fulfilled hundreds of years
before Jesus came on the scene.
There were prophecies given that he ended up fulfilling.
Now you can go read this online somewhere.
You can read books about this.
Scholars actually debate the number of prophecies
because we define prophecy differently at times
that Jesus actually fulfilled.
But at a minimum, at a minimum,
it's well over 200 specific prophecies
that Jesus fulfilled when he showed up.
And in his life. Sometimes people say up
to almost 400 prophecies
that Jesus fulfilled from the Old Testament hundreds years
before Jesus filled them out.
Lemme give you some examples.
The time of his birth where he was born in Bethlehem,
that he was gonna be born of a virgin,
that he would be betrayed for 30 pieces of silver,
that he would be mocked, crucified, pierced, all
that was predicted that he would die with the wicked
but be buried with the rich.
That was which tomb he was put in
that he'd be from the geneal genealogy
of David and so many more.
Those are examples of things said hundreds of years
before that Jesus fulfilled two exactness,
which Jesus even kind of proves here in Matthew 21, he turns
to his two disciples
and he predicts when they go into
this village, what are they gonna find?
A donkey with a a mom donkey with its unwritten
child, its cult.
And he says, go find them. Bring 'em back.
And they're like, okay. And they
go in there and they, what do they find?
They find a mother donkey with an unwritten cult. Hello?
It's supposed to point them
to something like Jesus is the fulfillment, which the,
again, the proof of that is Zechariah nine verse nine,
that the Messiah would show up
as a humble king on a young donkey.
Jesus said, watch this.
I'm gonna fulfill it in front of you.
They go and find it, bring it back.
That's how we get the triumphal entry.
So Jesus fulfilled prophecy.
But here's what's amazing about all this.
This just gets into some apologetics kind of stuff here.
You just take eight prophecies,
I mentioned seven or eight, nine, right there.
Just take eight of them.
The statistical probability of one person
fulfilling just eight of those
is something like one in 10 to the 17th power.
Now I know you can't even visualize that number,
so let's put it up on the screen.
That's one with 17 zeros behind it,
100 quadrillion.
Imagine if you covered the state of Texas with nickels
one foot deep and you reach in
and you pick out the one red nickel randomly out
of the entire place
and you pick the right one the first time.
That is the probability statistically
of one person fulfilling just eight Jesus over 200, up
to 400, fulfilled them all.
That's stunning, isn't it?
Like only God, there's no randomness to this.
Only God could have set all this up for it to exactly happen
as it did to prove who he is.
So while they both fulfilled prophecy Jesus,
of course in a lot bigger way, but they both did.
Here's the second comparison.
Both David and the son of David cared for the outcast.
They cared for the outcast.
Think about David at the end of one Samuel.
We saw him kind of stepping into the kingship.
What was he doing? He was,
his heart was right towards being the king.
He was walking in a way that his,
his focus was on delivering people from
the oppression they were in.
He was defeating the oppressors he was protecting
and providing for people.
That was what the king was supposed to do.
He was doing it as he needed to.
We'll see it even more in Second Samuel.
There's a forgotten son
of Saul who's crippled from a young age
and David takes him into his own family.
Essentially. He cared for the outcast.
Well, let's just take here in Matthew 21 in this just
the temple scene.
Just one little glimpse of Jesus' life. Way more than this.
But look what this showed us.
He drove out those who were keeping people from worshiping.
He healed the blind
and the lame as those things kept people from worshiping,
they had to stay out in the courtyard.
They could come in now if they were healed.
He loved children in ways few other leaders did.
Those kids themselves saw the Messiah.
They're like, this is the one.
Nobody else loved the children like that.
See, what this is saying is that all of it points
to the fact that Jesus came to fulfill
prophecy from Isaiah 700 years earlier.
This is what Jesus himself identified with Luke four.
He says, the spirit of the Lord is upon me.
He's anointed me to proclaim good news to the poor.
He sent me to proclaim liberty to the captives recovering
of sight to the blind to set it liberty, those
who are oppressed to proclaim the year of the Lord's favor.
That's what Jesus came to do.
In fact, that's also what the kings
of Israel were supposed to do.
Similar things like that, care for the outcast,
make this a safe place for everyone to live.
And so we can compare Jesus,
I just dabbled in the surface of that a little bit.
We can compare them, but they're not equals.
So we also need to contrast them.
There's some contrast between David
and Jesus that we can learn a lot about Jesus through those.
Again, just look at this temple scene.
Matthew 21, look at verses 12
and 13, specifically, Jesus entered the temple,
drove out all who sold and bought in the temple
and he overturned the tables, the money changers
and the seats of those who sold pigeons.
And he said to them, it is written again,
this was quoted from Isaiah 56.
My house shall be called a house of prayer.
But you make it a den of robbers.
Now, unfortunately, what I've heard people do with
that passage, they've actually given them,
given people license for temper tantrums
and said, Hey man, they deserved it.
They deserved it. I get to do it because they deserved it.
Like, no, that's not what this is saying.
This is teaching us something really important about Jesus
and we might miss it if we're only focused on what he did
with the tables and all that kind of stuff.
'cause remember the temple's purpose, that was the place
that God dwelled among his people.
That was the place that people received
forgiveness for their sins.
That's how that mechanism worked.
It was a location for worship.
It was where all nations were
supposed to come and be blessed.
That was why God installed the temple.
Yet the religious leaders
at the time had abused it for their own gain.
They had started to lose the mission of the temple.
So Jesus needed to come overturn it.
It had abandoned its original purpose.
And so God said, Jesus, here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna flip the tables of this thing.
But don't forget, again, we're contrasting David and Jesus.
Don't forget that, that the tabernacle was
David's system of worship.
That's where David would worship.
That's where David needed to receive forgiveness
through sacrifices.
That was where the worship happened. David was in that.
So the contrast here is that David was in that system,
but Jesus, we saw it here, was over that system.
Right David, that's how he worshiped the son of David,
though he's over that
he was over the system.
He had the authority to come in
and hit the reset button on the whole thing.
This is wrong. This is wrong.
What authority does he have to say that?
Well, he showed it just a couple days later
because not only did he flip the tables in the temple,
he also repeatedly said that his body is the temple.
You tear it down. Three days later I'll build it back up.
And they were like, you can't build this building like that.
He's like, I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about the true temple.
And So his authority to do that, proven by his death
and resurrection over all the system, he can do it.
And what we learned from that is that we don't come to God
through a building anymore.
We come to God through a person, the Son
of God in the flesh.
The Son of David is the way to the Father now,
not through any system
or through a person like David, it's through the son
of God, the Son of Dave.
So David was in the system. Jesus was over the system.
There's one more contrast though I wanna make between David
and Jesus and and it highlights again
how great our God is in
that He would send his son to be this Messiah.
Watch this. Do you remember how David was referred to
by Samuel, by God, by others?
What was kind of his, his catchphrase.
His title was one Samuel 13, 14.
It says, the Lord has sought out a man
after his own heart.
Remember that? And that's how David's referred to a man
after God's own heart, which means that he was longing
for God, he wanted God, he pursued God.
And that's great. It's an example for all of us.
We should be men and women who are our hearts are after God.
Like want him long for him, love him.
But when we contrast David with Jesus,
we see something even greater show
Up.
See, David merely had a heart after God.
Jesus though was
God's very heart,
Right? David had a
heart after God. Yes, he, he loved God.
He wanted God. He had a heart after God.
Yet Jesus was God's very heart in the flesh.
He was God's heart.
He was God's heart in the flesh.
Listen to what Colossians one says In Jesus,
all the fullness of God was pleased to dwell.
It means everything that's in God is God and is in Jesus.
Like, don't miss this. What we're saying here is that
that like John one says, the Son of God
took on flesh and dwelt among us.
That means Jesus did not lose divinity in any way.
He just added on a human nature to his divinity.
It's not like 50 50 half human, half God, he's 100% God
and 100% man.
And it blows our minds to think about that. But that's true.
He did not lose anything.
All that is in God, the very heart of God is seen in Jesus.
So that's why this is so important.
Church, when we look at Jesus, we see God,
everything about Jesus, whatever it is,
it shows us who God is.
Why am I telling you this? Because when we look at
that temple scene And they saw the wonderful works
that Jesus was doing, when we look at that scene, we saw two
very different responses to this.
Jesus, did you notice, right?
The chief priests and the scribes,
what'd they feel? They were threatened
By this Jesus.
They
Instead of repenting, they doubled down,
got frustrated, and ultimately led the charge in having
Jesus crucified just a couple days
Later, We're about to lose everything guys.
He, he's look at all
the people that're already going after him.
We're about to lose it all. We better take care of that.
That's one response in the temple.
But there was a second response. Who was it? The children.
The children recognizing who Jesus was.
They praised him for it.
And that is a fulfillment of Psalm eight, verse two,
which says, outta the mouths of babes
and infants, you've prepared praise
that they look at this Jesus.
And what they see is God
two very different responses to the same moment,
the same things they all saw, and these children looked
and worshiped the Messiah.
So that leaves us with the question then,
how do you see Jesus
if this is who he is?
How Do you see Jesus?
Are you trusting him to be your savior?
And I don't just mean like eternity.
I got my fire insurance. I'm not gonna end up away from God.
I'm gonna be with him like I, I'm trusting him for that.
Are you trusting him to be your savior in the middle
of your mess today, in the middle
of it all right now?
Or are you looking for a different kind of savior?
Are you looking for one who just improves your kingdom?
Now, I wrestled with this all week.
I asked myself like, okay, how do I know?
I don't want I, I wanna trust him in the right ways.
I wanna trust him as king
and God I I don't want to trust him just
to help me like make my life easier.
How do I know? Same question you're asking. How do we know?
Here's a good heart check question.
Think about what you pray for
when you examine your prayer life.
Think about what you pray for.
Is it for comfort or character?
When you pray, God save me. God deliver me.
Are you praying for comfort or for character?
Are you praying That God's some kind of vending machine
that you can get peace and comfort and ease and a nice life
and that's what you want God to save you for four?
Or are you praying for God to shape you in your character
through the difficult time?
Yes, you can pray that God would take it, but
but your heart is not in hoping that would happen.
Your heart is saying, God shaped me into the image of Jesus
that I know you're doing right now.
I surrender to your plan not to
what I think my life should look like.
That is a whole different way of praying, right?
For comfort or for character. Which one are you praying?
That's how we can see.
Are you praying that God's this vending machine giving you
good things, blessings, all the things that you would want?
Or are you praying like Thomas
did now love this passage?
When Thomas saw Jesus
after Jesus resurrected for the first time Thomas saw him.
Here's how he responded.
He said, my Lord
and my God,
that's how we should see Jesus.
Do you see the son of David like that?
Or do you see the son of David as
this other lesser savior?
Do you see him as your king?
Do you see him as the one in charge, as the one
who you submit to as the God over all that he is the true
and better David who conquered our greatest enemies of sin
and death and ourselves.
That's who we should be looking for.
Instead of this son of David, like the crowd saw him,
who praised him one day, yet abandoned him
and called for his crucifixion just a few days later,
looking for the wrong kind of salvation.
Again, remember, Jesus came not to improve our kingdom,
but to bring us into his.
So let's respond to him with that Hosanna idea. Save us.
But with the right kind of perspective that who we're asking
to save us is the king over all things.
And his plan is better than ours.